the klas channel 8 phone Bank is open
today answering your questions about
Medicare eligibility Medicare Advantage
plans and why seniors should consider
taking a look at their existing plans
during medicare's annual enrollment
period now if you are 65 or older or you
will be soon this information is for you
and we have Colby Baker a licensed
Medicare agent to talk to us about
medicare's annual enrollment period
welcome Colby so many questions let's
just start off what is medicare's annual
enrollment period it's a good question
and first of all I just want to say on
behalf of the whole Humana team we're
excited to be here to help out in any
way that we can so Medicare Advantage
and our sorry Medicare open enrollment
period or annual enrollment period is
really it runs from October 15th through
December 7th okay so during that period
companies that offer insurance plans for
Medicare will make changes to their
plans they do that every year and so
this is the period of the year that
Medicare beneficiaries people that are
on Medicare or starting Medicare can
make changes to their plans now I know a
lot of people have so many questions we
encourage you to call one that I keep
hearing is what is Medicare and Medicare
Advantage what's the difference so
Medicare consists of two parts Part A
and Part B okay part A is the hospital
insurance and Part B is the medical
insurance and that's really just
covering the basics you know uh cope
Hospital insurance is going to be the
room in the bed for the hospital Part B
is going to be you know doctor visits or
outpatient services and things like that
which leaves some gaps in what can be
covered right so then these insurance
companies will come up with other types
of plans Medicare Advantage being one of
them also Medicare supplements okay and
so during this period Medicare
beneficiaries can make changes based on
what their needs are and that's why you
guys are here to help us to answer the
questions call the eight phone bank now
and get your questions answered
702-650-1101 is the number they will be
answering your calls until 7 pm thank
you so much for the great information
Kendall